hi askearn bris welcome to Spooky's
House of jump-scares
finally oh my god it was commented so
much please play more please play more
apparently they didn't have more rooms
than 500 it's the game is still in
development but the developer just wrote
to me and he said there's 250 more rooms
to go throw so lets life stupidest [ __ ]
alright room 500 baby hey yep how I roll
baby
i won I am placing thanks we can't go in
that one right oh we can oh great
we have 250 [ __ ] rooms to go through
Jesus Christ
I forgot forgot hug tediousness king
miss just don't jump-scare me I don't
like gyms hey this is kind of [ __ ]
creepy alright hello oh god I hear
something oh my god whoa no not the mask
again please for the love of God not the
[ __ ] mask uh-oh Oh what what is
happening hello did not ask for this oh
my oh my oh Jesus
stop please no no no no no no no no no
no no no no what the [ __ ] are you okay
then just gonna go back I can't go back
hey oh my god
my brain is melting I can feel it I feel
it in my fingers I feel it in my ass
oh hell better stop the fire oh my god
[ __ ] curious skeletons man what is
this desert Jared ah ah ah what the [ __ ]
is wrong with it ah
what the [ __ ]
an axe
whoa whoo
the graphics of this game is [ __ ]
wonderful I gotta say no no no no not
the dearest anything but the dares
hey hey hey Bambi hey okay okay
[ __ ] oh no oh god damn they added a
lot of [ __ ] in this game Hannibal I
don't like this man awful far six
hundred baby Wow hang in there Kitty oh
hey what it says fine as a phrase no no
no no no you think hello if you want to
look directly to the Fed um yes hello um
hello
oh you want to look directly to the Fed
um yes hello um hello
I don't trust anything anymore [ __ ]
me Nene please I have that ref call cap
seriously awesome free game I gotta say
really impressed by this Oh Oh God
dedicating baby he got here Thanks oh no
no no no oh the fence no no no
no this is so scary Oh
Oh it's a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
not gonna stay for you friend okay ah ah
90 rooms left baby 90 rooms pros oh you
son of a fluffy [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
that's right I cut you in here [ __ ]
okay
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
whoa what a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh oh
48 more baby we can don't wet brows we
can know what all along yeah I don't
like this though I feel like they gonna
playing some [ __ ] for them you know what
I mean somebody else can't get as
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh hello oh my god oh my god what just
aah what was that aah [ __ ] what is this
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope oh oh oh
Oh
Oh damnit I think I think I think I
think AB no no no no no no cow
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is not
nice
ah you [ __ ] ass-licking
[ __ ] [ __ ] where's the door
neh doo dah
what why did it [ __ ] with me so hard
last time ah
ah all right 30 more baby 30 more high
five I'm not with my head haha hey 750
baby
Oh get it
I got an eggs mmm this game is really
amazing it's scary it's funny it's
unique its intimate --iv and I love this
style so I got I got a huge props to the
developer of this game I really really
love it they like video if you look
forward to part three and I will see you
bros in the next one thank you so much
for watching stay awesome
I don't know what's up with that I don't
know what the [ __ ] is hot oh my god is
spider
hahaha [ __ ] sexy this game is just
like from humiliation your humiliation